actuellement une équipe personne est
actuellement sur l'autre plateau pour
régler le problème d'apprendre ou à
laisser qu'on va faire dans un instant
et oui hier va gagner son milo on va
faire les missions aujourd'hui voilà et
puis demain mais maladroit donc les
chéris donc là pour ce plateau on me le
confirme c'est ok c'est ok tout est ok
regardez une question contrôle je vois
sur à prendre ou à laisser on est dessus
une équipe de deux personnes de deux
professionnelles et professionnels de
l'audiovisuel sont actuellement de tout
mettre en oeuvre pour pouvoir faire
cette émission anglaise stagiaires on va
se retrouver dans un instant pour c'est
que du qui est ce que vous êtes chaud
oui je sais pas si nous a porté l'âge
coût est de retour et ont pu alors il ya
notre public aujourd'hui c'est raïssa et
je vous le dis il ya une énorme d'arc à
ce soir c'est quand même qu'à mon fils
qui est quand même en dessous le pupitre
est tranquille mais reproduit celle
d'arras et voilà c'est ça c'est ça c'est
8 jeu s'avère au shérif qui se fait à
layoule à l'amiable et bien tu as passé
là deux heures bien mon chéri d'amour
bien quand même bien monsieur bien voilà
que la pub dire de passants ouais
relance la pub on arrive dans un instant
ils avaient peur voilà vous voyez pas ce
qu'il est avec moi pour la loi